[Musique]
le tgv est parti lentement de la
rochelle pour belfort où il va trouver
ses moteurs le tgv je crois que ça veut
dire le train à grande vitesse le plus
rapide du monde avec le tgv le turbo
trains à grande vitesse
la sncf espère franchir une nouvelle
étape dans l'augmentation de la vitesse
de pointe tout en améliorant confort et
sécurité une partie de la rame prototype
vient d'être réalisée à la rochelle dans
une usine de matériel ferroviaire
ces grandes vitesses nécessite des
conceptions spécial l'emploi d'acier à
haute limite élastique a permis de
réduire le poids 25 tonnes par voiture
contre 45 à une voiture normale
la sonorisation était poussé au maximum
le conditionnement d'air et du type
aviation aux trois voitures construites
à la rochelle vont s'en ajouter deux
autres en cours de réalisation à belfort
la rame prototype comportera donc cinq
voitures dont deux motrices pilotes aux
extrémités une voiture de première avec
34 place une voiture de 2e classe et une
voiture laboratoire une particularité du
tgv ses bogies son moteur le courant
électrique produit par les deux motrices
est envoyé dans les moteurs placés dans
les six bougies de la ramq pour
constituer une sorte de chez nous les
premiers essais de vitesse sont prévues
entre mulhouse et belfort
le tgv doit rapidement atteindre les 200
à l'heure dans un premier temps pour
s'attaquer ensuite aux 300 km/heure 300
km heure c'est l'ambition de la sncf qui
veut en faire le train le plus rapide du
monde pour détrôner le tokaïdo et ses
210 km à l'heure
[Musique]